let's just start with quick intro so
Linda after you hi I'm Linda I'm
co-founder of a crypto hedge fund called
scalar capital we focus on long-term
investing this space with the strong
emphasis on privacy coins and then
before that I was a product manager at
coinbase
joined pretty early on and just been
passionate about crypto currencies for a
very long time
cool hey I'm a virtual serial
entrepreneur part time at YC I'm in
crypto since 2013 actively invest in
currencies and various companies and
this is a where I spend a lot of my time
thinking about the way things are going
and what the future holds and where
we'll end up in the next 10 years cuz I
think this is a pretty fascinating area
cool well it sounds like you guys are
the right people because we have a ton
of crypto questions and let's start with
definitions I know a lot of the
listeners probably know or have a loose
understanding of what blockchain with
Bitcoin all this stuff is but just so we
establish kind of a ground truth Linda
why don't we start with you
what is a blockchain a blockchain is
essentially a decentralized public
ledger where you can have a recording of
all the transactions that have happened
on it without having a centralized
entity that's kind of dictating what
what happens or someone that can
manipulate the data and all of this is
just done in a decentralized fashion so
you don't have to trust who's actually
controlling this data what are the other
things that people ought to know I think
that so it's important to separate like
a crypto currency from new new coins
that have come out that are essentially
people refer them it's crypto assets
because it's essentially more than just
money at this point
so aetherium is a smart contracts
platform and smart contracts are
essentially you can think of it just
like a contract that is essentially just
programmable logic where you essentially
have a decentralized network of
computers that's executing this logic
without having to rely on a centralized
source that can get shut down or
manipulate the information or data so a
smart contract in itself is just really
important and you can kind of if you
want to compare it to Bitcoin just think
of it as a bit more powerful than
Bitcoin and that you can be a little bit
more programmable anything dad yeah the
way I think that's great I agree with
everything linda said so far I think the
way I think about it there's like four
core concepts there's blockchain which
is I think Linda covered well as
distributed ledger and
a bunch of properties around who can
read it and how you write to the ledger
and so on I think there's this notion of
consensus which is how do we all agree
on what gets written to the blockchain
and what the universal truth is and
there are different mechanisms to agree
on on the truth there's the idea of a
token or token economics which is how do
we align the incentives of all the
actors in the space and there are
different mechanisms to aligning the
incentives and then I think there's the
smart contracting layer which is assume
you have a ledger and you have tokens
and people who are agreeing on the state
of the universe what what degree of
control and program ability do we give
on top of that to the users of the
blockchain other programmers to do
interesting things on top of that which
is I think where things like
programmable money or distributed
compute it really interesting those are
kind of like the four things that I
think about in this universe and you can
kind of mash them together in different
ways and different chains mash them
together into guys yeah absolutely so we
should explain those there are many use
cases for distributed Ledger's for
programmable money all of these things
can we let's break those apart and we
had a ton of questions about it but just
from broad broad strokes what are the
use cases you guys see especially
whenever there's a middleman that's
doing programming logic and saying
if-then condition and is charging fries
for that you can replace them with a
smart contract so there's plenty of use
cases for that and financial system
health care legal system so I I view
that is really powerful of just
automating things and allowing - there
to not be a centralized point of failure
and I think that's one of the most
important parts of what this produces
yeah I think I level the way I think
about it is there there are kind of
three buckets there are there's
essentially programmable money and
there's a bunch of different facets of
that there's privacy or they're smart
contracts can be used as escrow and you
could argue icos effectively are in
escrow or you're like locking up some
sum and then you can do something with
on the other side so it's kind of like
programmable money is like one bucket of
use cases just you really compute is
another bucket of use cases like you can
use all these computers all around the
world to execute code and then the third
bucket is distributed apps so things
like prediction markets or distributed
VPN networks and and that's kind of the
third bucket of use cases and I think
pretty much everything I've seen so far
con falls into one of those three and
sometimes there's a little
an overlap you could be kind of in two
buckets but a high label I think those
are the three buckets I think about cool
and so to jump into a question from
Twitter
JPS what are the top use cases you guys
think are gonna go mainstream in three
years and mainstream maybe caveat it by
like within this community but yeah yeah
the two ones that I think will come in
streamer decentralize exchange and and
probably gaming something along the
lines of collectibles so decentralize
just define collectibles like what's an
example of that that's been out in the
world right so out in the world in the
crypto community there's been crypto
kitties so you can collect a unique
digital cat on the blockchain and so
that can never be destroyed you own that
permanently and so that just got really
popular people were kind of just
collecting it like just digital beanie
babies in a way you can breed them
together and produce new unique cats but
people just love collecting things in
general I mean that's a that's been very
common with like stamps and coins and
cars like people just love collecting
and now and you have a society where you
can just collect everything in a digital
manner and you can freely trade this and
so that pairs well to me with the
centralized exchange because so for
context I worked at a centralized
exchange where you essentially have this
exchange controlling user funds and so
coinbase is really trustworthy and I'm
fine I'm storing my phone's on coinbase
but there are a lot of centralized
exchanges out there that have risk of
getting hacked or getting shun tapping
regulators running with user funds so
there's there's risk on the custody side
there's also some barriers to entry if
you live in a jurisdiction that just
something like coinbase doesn't support
or you don't have the right
documentation so I'm really excited
about decentralized exchange because you
can now have a bunch of people that can
participate in these markets and trade
anything they want yeah trade digital
cats if they want and it's it's really
cool and so more people could just
participate in the network at this point
yeah I think the same thing is true like
are those of the UC use cases that
happen in the next couple years yeah I
think both of those will happen the the
two others I'd add or the the big one
the other big one I'd add basically is
is programmable money I think like
payment the payment rails will all get
built out things like lightning network
and plasma or zero fee payment networks
that are coming
and I think the merchant side of those
things will continue to get better and
so I think payments as a category stuff
will happen and then kind of privacy as
a subset of that to I think private
privacy tokens are actually a thing if
you talk to a lot of people
hey if X Y Z thing went away would you
would you care about it like yeah it
would be kind of unfortunate if that
went away or I lose a lot of money
accepting the ICO and then you talk to
people you say what would you miss it if
Manero went away and I can't man that
would be really terrible because I
actually use manera to do something hmm
so I think I think the payment side of
things was actually gonna merge and then
yeah I agree I think decentralized
exchanges and collectibles are too early
like real use cases that people actually
yes and and what about the decentralized
apps that people are talking about and
kind of dreaming about now what what's
the timeline on something like that I
think probably this is probably a place
where we might differ I think it's
probably like seven to ten years out for
most of these I think we're really
really early in most of these cases
there might be one off use cases like
orchid with VPN where there's that's
like a real problem and being a
distributed network and a decentralized
network yeah can be can be censorship
resistant and so that's like a core
feature of the network beyond that I'm I
think it'll be it'll be a while I think
there will be some early use cases but
by and large it's gonna take several
years yeah I generally agree I think my
time spans just a little bit shorten
maybe like three to five but I think
that there's there's a lot of scaling
issues that need to be solved before
anything can go mainstream um but I I'm
generally a pretty optimistic that
there's a lot of really smart people
working on that problem right now
mm-hmm and be more specific on the
technical side what are the scaling
issues yeah so with aetherium crypto
kitties itself was so popular so many
people are trying to use it
Bitcoin itself so many people have been
actually trying to use Bitcoin that the
transaction fees have actually gotten
pretty high and at some points it was
like average thirty dollars per
transaction for you which is like
parallel to a wire at that point so you
you you have so many people that's I
mean it's a good problem so many people
want to use it but it's too expensive
and it starts getting really slow and
then in the theorems case I know there's
a lot of scaling work being done so l4
is an organization that was funded by
the etherium community grant to
essentially work on some scaling
solutions there's a lot of different
ones that they're tackling they're
supposed to be working on stage
which essentially you can kind of if I
were to compare this I it's kind of just
like a bar tab in a way where you
essentially have all these like offline
transactions where people are just like
moving back and forth between each other
and you can update you can update state
and essentially you can update logic and
then only when you want to finalize
something you can move it back to the
main chain so it's just a bunch of off
chain transactions
there's also plasma which is Joseph poon
and Vitalik wrote about which
essentially you have block chains within
block chains and so you just like have
all this work being done on these like
block chains within a main block chain
and if you ever want to because the idea
is that you don't really care about what
everyone else is doing you only really
care about what your transactions are
all about yeah so you're like isolated
in your own little block chain and only
when something goes wrong do you ever
have to like leave that block chain and
like go back to the main one and report
something strong so there's all kinds of
like things going on with this so just
to understand that like buy your own
block chain are you meaning individual
users or individual apps on a blockchain
both I mean essentially you can just be
isolated in your own world in whatever
application or even individual use cases
so this is very theoretical right now
but there's like work being done on it
there's also true bits working on doing
off chain computations so essentially
you don't want really complex
computation on if you're in blockchain
you essentially can maybe move that off
and pay people for computational to be
done and essentially the problem is that
you have to verify that the work was
done correctly so they have a really
really cool concept where you
essentially have force you force errors
in the network so you essentially every
once in a while the network will do some
wrong computation and something that is
incorrect and people who catch that
error actually get compensated for that
so you have this whole network where
people are just constantly making sure
that things are running correctly
because if they catch something they get
a payout for it so there's just a bunch
of really cool work being done out so
I'm generally pretty optimistic it the
ability to actually go mainstream and do
you think that many of these apps that
we're gonna see are going to resemble
things that are popular right now or is
this sort of like very much like the
beginning of the internet and
we had no idea what was coming and it'll
look more like that than you know a dupe
of what we have right now yeah I think
it'll be that's a great question I think
the early ideas will look like ports of
stuff that were used to there's like the
early internet was kind of like the New
York Times took the newspaper and
literally like nytimes.com headlines or
images
yeah it was the Newman Charlie yeah it
looks like the newspaper writes just
because it's like that's the easiest way
to transport to a new platform and we
just couldn't predict it social media
that actually like Facebook and Twitter
would be the actual media winners or
YouTube would be the actual media when
it wouldn't be you know like CNN and so
I think and I think it would have been
really challenging to predict something
like Airbnb yeah if you could have
called that then you know well you you
have done quite well as an investor but
also you know every be if you look at
their early funding history it was just
really challenging for them because it's
such an out-there idea but it was it was
a native idea it was a thing that made
sense on the internet so I think the the
first set of ideas will be essentially
ports and there'll be people trying to
sort of cargo cult kind I mean app the
idea is over yeah and then a couple
years into it people who are sort of
think about these things natively will
start to play with ideas and say oh well
now you can do this thing that just
wasn't possible before and here's an
idea and what do you know if I push a
button a car can come to me instead of
me going to someplace right and so those
ideas I think it just takes a while for
people to get used to it and for
developers to play with the the
infrastructure and the concepts and just
sort of like poke around and play around
and see what's possible do you think
it'll leapfrog by location in any way so
for example you know how LA was
perfectly situated to have cars but you
know medieval European cities weren't
yeah and so they kind of then get
leapfrogged and have the train
infrastructure do you think that will
happen with you know a decentralized app
so say for instance you know in Africa
somewhere where like you know money is
not the same thing as it is here in
terms of like payment accessibility and
and most things will they take off in
different places first or will that not
be the case personally I never thought
cryptocurrencies were gonna take off in
the US or anything at first I think it's
gonna be in countries where people don't
have bank accounts primarily and they
now need a method of actually storing
their own funds or countries where their
currency is just getting inflated away
and so the currency is not valuable so I
find that like in certain countries the
use cases of cryptocurrency actually
matter more than in countries where
there's a really strong financial
infrastructure so yeah it definitely
varies in my kit and so there's also
something like in China where you have
all this censorship of using different
applications I could really see
decentralized applications taking off in
China yeah yeah I just always wondered
like has is the valley a good barometer
of the popularity of cryptocurrency and
decentralized apps or is it not that's
what I've been wondering I'd take a
question yeah in some sense geography is
just one is like one specific way to say
that there's an underserved market yeah
and I think you will probably see things
like the inspiration for new ideas does
tend to take hold in these underserved
markets and so geography is certainly
one dimension or you could have argued
that you know college students were or
an underserved market and it came to
social networks and it's just like they
were all in one place there's like an
opportunity for a new type of media to
emerge and so you know I think there
will be pockets even even in developed
countries there are pockets that are
underserved and so the question is
really where other underserved markets
where the new infrastructure gives you
some sort of fundamental advantage or
some sort of new utility and then
there's a kind of a related question
which is even if that's worth the
inspiration for the idea comes from how
do the companies that build those
products actually scale which i think is
actually a different dimension
altogether and so it's it's you know if
you think about where the bottlenecks
for actually building companies are I
think a lot of that is tribal knowledge
that's in people's heads it's like what
does it mean to have like a fast-growing
startup so coinbase for example is a YC
company right it's actually not a
coincidence to me it's just like what it
takes to actually build a fast-growing
startup it turns out there's a lot of
traditional like best practices about
how you hire people on how you structure
teams and how you raise capital and like
a bunch of that stuff is like that
tribal knowledge is in people's heads in
Silicon Valley and so I think you could
have the inspiration for ideas come from
underserved markets but I wouldn't be
surprised if the really big winners in
crypto actually every centralized around
Silicon Valley hmm Oh same way yeah I
generally feel the same way I mean
there's a lot of developers that are I
hear about are working on aetherium
applications in their spare time and so
you're seeing a flock of
per talent from Silicon Valley into
working in this space and I think that
that's where you're going to see a lot
of innovation although it is it is
pretty nice to see that there are like
different hubs around the world of
blockchain development so there's like
Berlin and I know places in Argentina
and Switzerland is another area so like
it's it's pretty cool to see like more
hubs pop up in the space
yeah and how how much do you think
governance and regulation is going to
affect those hubs like does it
ultimately mean just like there's a
certain density of people that can build
the stuff therefore I'm moving there or
are these tax incentives different
regulations actually going to move the
market yeah I think it's really going to
move the market so right now I think the
u.s. is being smart and not trying to be
overly restrictive because they'll know
that it will push out a lot of the
development especially let's say you
were to just really be harsh on people
that were developing on these projects
and I think that that would easily just
cause people just move elsewhere you're
already seeing the tax incentives play
out here so people are registering in
Cayman Islands or Puerto Rico starting a
little like hub of people buying houses
imported yeah yeah yes so you're already
seen I actually know if you feel they're
trying to move out of California
especially because California's that's
really high taxes yeah yeah well you see
Nevada plates here all the time yeah and
even even like when you have scenarios
where people are like mining in China
and then also in China starts cracking
down on mining these miners have to move
elsewhere and you're seeing like people
move over to Washington because
electricity is cheap so there's like
this like movement and just based off
cheap electricity as well so yeah it's
pretty fascinating I think I mean the
whole regulatory arbitrage angle to this
stuff is pretty fascinating yes how our
governments the game theory around how
governments want to to regulate this
stuff is pretty pretty interesting I
actually think that US government has
been really really smart about this and
pretty measured and sophisticated
because I think they understand there's
a lot of potential for innovation here
and a lot of value be created and they
don't want to crush that and I've been
actually pretty impressed with how
measured they've been I mean you look at
something like the the BTC the Bitcoin
ETF paperwork that went in and all these
people filing for it I thought it was it
was so clever the way
that they essentially pushed back on
that they didn't actually reject the the
ETF proposals
it essentially convinced the people who
had put in the ETF proposals to withdraw
the proposal yeah which I thought was
super clever so they basically
back-channel now I think I don't have
any inside information just to be clear
but my read on it was what they did was
they went to the to the teams and said
hey look there are a lot of reasons we
can't approve this right now maybe it
was like hey we don't want to inflate
the bubble anymore or you know whatever
else
why don't you withdraw them and let's
keep talking and then that way it wasn't
like the government rejected the ETF
proposals it was the ETF proposals are
being withdrawn just absolutely the
right way to do it right if you're like
hey look we're gonna do this eventually
we just can't do this right now but we
don't crush the market we already don't
want to pump up the market really smart
way to do it and so they've actually
think been pretty sophisticated like the
regulator's inside the SEC and the CFTC
and so on they've been actually pretty
sophisticated in the way they're
handling this and what about on the
Investor side how do you guys feel about
you know accredited investors getting
involved in icos versus not accredited
yeah I mean that one's hard because I
really believe in decentralized systems
and everyone should have access to this
but at the same time if something
straight-up looks like a security token
and you're issuing it in the US I think
that it rightfully falls under the SEC
regulation so I I do believe in
compliance and that's actually something
I really like about this new protocol
harbor protocol we're essentially trying
to make sure that the trading of tokens
is compliant so you can have some
whitelist of just accredited investors
that plug into the smart contract and
essentially say that you can only ever
issue tokens to these investors and
there's maybe some holding requirement
you have to hold it for 90 days or
something so the smart contract itself
will have the logic that you can't
actually trade these tokens so I do
think that it's important to be
complying with this as long as it's very
clear it's the security token although I
really think that there are plenty of
cases where like a governance token
doesn't fall under that jurisdiction so
it's really important to kind of like
make the distinction that not all tokens
are the same yeah agree with all that
and the risk really is that I mean the
there's no there's a whole like
philosophical angle to this right which
is to what degree should the government
be involved in and being somewhat
paternal about
about protecting investors from this up
from themselves in some sense right and
and these distinctions are arbitrary
it's like if you have a certain amount
of money you get to sort of doing every
one and if you don't then you don't
right so and you know that's starting to
change with crowd funding regulations
that have changed recently and and so
there is some movement there so setting
aside the kind of philosophical parts of
it I think generally speaking trying to
prevent scammers in the ecosystem and
trying to prevent people from kind of
getting built and losing their money I
think is important and good and to the
extent that the ecosystem can do that
itself things like Harbor which i think
is pretty awesome as your project I
think the to the extent that we can kind
of like make that easy for people to not
lose their money or people inside the
ecosystem calling out okay this is what
I've been wondering right yet like
because you know the ico market has been
rife with these I mean like not
necessarily scams but sometimes
straight-up yeah right and it's not
actually good for anyone yeah I mean
maybe it's good for the one scammer who
gets a bunch of money yeah but in the
long run it's not good for anyone yeah
yeah so like is this the only way what
other methods are being put in place to
avoid these scams
yeah I'm really helping people who are
in the ecosystem are very aggressive
about calling these things out yeah
and not supporting them and I think
ultimately if if there are ways for
people to call out these projects and
then those projects don't receive any
funding that's that's actually you know
like the economic incentives will kind
of play out in the right way yeah and so
I think you know people will get smarter
about it people will get more
sophisticated about diligence and
investors can kind of help I think the
people who actually are sophisticated
and understand the technology and have
done diligence and understand how
product development works and understand
all these nuances I think actually
getting out there and saying like hey
this is the real good stuff right true
bit super interesting project you know
like and there's real tech there and the
team is really smart and like so on
right and just like talking about it and
saying by the way this stuff over here
be careful right like yeah and I don't
call anybody out but like you know it's
there there's stuff out there that if
you just talk to people who are deep in
it you can sort of like poke and prod
and realize that it's it's a little bit
more vaporware I think people just need
to be more proactive about that yeah
there there was an interesting case
where there was a there's a project
called crypto all-stars resin she had
collectibles of different crypto
celebrities so there
like one furnivall and charlie and so if
you like verified on Twitter that you
were actually them the the card owner
you essentially got four percent of the
proceeds of the card and then the
creator of the project got four percent
but anyways this this was like really
really popular and people are trading
this and it pretty much like looked like
a pyramid scheme in a way and someone
actually bought the website and bought
it from the project owners and claiming
they wanted to improve it and they
actually shut it down and so they like
someone bought it pays what I think it
was like ten thousand dollars or
something like that and then just shut
down the website and said like hey this
is like straight up a scam and like
people are pumping the prices on Twitter
and people are gonna lose a bunch of
money so I'm not okay with this I'm
shutting it down so I thought that was
like those I know crazy amazing yeah
yeah so things like that are happening
as well right like I it's probably like
would behoove me to do some research on
the beginning of the stock market
because I imagine in the beginning
things we're getting pumped in the same
way exactly I mean I think that's that
is the root of a lot of this regulation
is yeah people a lot of people lost a
lot of money you know 60 70 80 years ago
and so a collectively we all decided hey
it's probably better if we don't let
snake oil salesman come in and just like
take every money it's like better for
everybody though I think it's fair to
say you know maybe it I think it's
always good to revisit things that have
been around for you know 50 years and
say which of these things actually apply
today and how should we think about them
and actually we evolved them yeah but
you know you even before I guess at that
point hopefully I think there are people
in a community that are good about
calling these things out and stamping
out the the fraud before it really
happens you too big and too many people
lose too much money and so what for the
people in the community like the folks
interested in starting companies where
do you think the opportunities are now
and then maybe that maybe the real
question is where the opportunities four
years from now that they should start
working on right now you have a company
that's a great question what do you
think there's so many applications that
I feel like rely on some sort of
identity and reputation system because
in the end like even if it's a
decentralized system like if you're
doing a decentralized marketplace you
still have to trust that the
person you're buying and good friends
actually going to deliver to you so I
think it's really important to have like
some some reputation and identity system
that carries with you as you as you use
all these different applications and
we're still the very early days of that
so there's like things like you port and
civic but they're really rudimentary
compared to the identity systems that
exist in like regular financial systems
um so I'd really like to see people work
on that problem and another area is that
a lot of a lot of projects talk about
doing decentralized governance and they
say that they're going to use the tokens
actually upgrade the protocol over time
but there's so much research that needs
to be done there so I think there's
massive opportunity to really figure out
what's the best way to handle governance
in decentralized manner I think that
that's going to be a massive potential
yeah I just taking some notes I I just
came up with five that I think are
probably if you're a founder out there
like a wish everything you might one
crypto puppy so I think the first Lynda
talked about before is basically scaling
solutions there's a lot of actually
infra work to be done just around making
this stuff actually more scalable yeah
and I think everybody pretty much is an
agreement that they're just not enough
people actually working at that layer of
the problem and we could we could use a
lot more great developers poking around
there I think even more broadly speaking
that I think there are components of
infrastructure that are missing and so I
think identity as a component of
infrastructure is interesting I think
things like Oracle's are interesting I
think just this general idea of like how
do we know what's true and what's not
true and and there are like potentially
shared datasets that people would want
to cross projects or cross chain
projects I would bucket all that kind of
stuff inside infrastructure I think
there's financial infrastructure and
financial tooling like a lot of the
early use cases are basically payment
oriented or money oriented and so
there's much stuff to do there I think
there's a lot of dev tooling to be built
so it's just like the actual production
of us more contract how do you test this
stuff how do you deploy it there's a lot
of work to do there and then like a lot
of things I think the early use cases
will probably be somewhat trivial and
fun and so I think gaming and
collectibles and things like that will
be pretty interesting and maybe it's
truly native stuff like crypto
kitties maybe it's markets to buy and
sell those kinds of assets maybe it's
games from you know traditional gaming
companies sitting on top of crypto
somehow to do digital assets inside the
game or cross game digital assets so I
think a lot of the like really sort of
fun trivial stuff that can take
advantage of the new technology will be
a way to bootstrap in
I mean arguably I snuck in somebody
earlier today about you know in some
sense I SEOs are kind of the gaming use
case right it's kind of like a game way
it's a gambling use case and like that's
actually kind of what's happening as
people are just gambling it's real money
yeah and so it kind of makes sense right
that that would take off is like it kind
of matches the pattern of what you see
with early adoption technologies yet
again like gambling is an early adopter
right oh for sure yeah I mean is there a
porn crypto thing yes actually really
popular and uses really cool technology
so it's really great yeah what is it
doing
so I think it's like webcams where
people can just paste Bank coin or
something to them but they use like
state channel technology it's like
cutting-edge technology in aetherium
which is pretty incredible yeah one of
the one of the more awkward things I
guess with all the early adopter use
cases too is you want to like understand
them but you don't want to go like super
deep and like you know like in the
ecosystem you don't necessarily want to
be known as the change thanks ready yeah
yeah that's true yeah I haven't really
yeah but it was like oh yeah somebody's
doing
I don't actually know anybody's really
dug into it right yeah especially if you
don't massively cash in is like this
Bank chain guy yeah I'm just kind of
around yeah fair enough so what about
the extra I mean I cos have been
gigantic right people erased hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah six six I think
was six billion last year's the number
three billion alone yeah well it was the
largest one so far yes yeah it's
probably yes yeah I think they're up to
a billion I think probably they're like
two billion now jeez yeah yeah so this
like fundamentally shifts the paradigm
for fund raising
so that's we I mean we've kind of like
gone from zero miles an hour to 120
miles an hour yeah in this conversation
but like for people who don't fully
understand when someone raises a billion
dollars straight up hey what are these
what are the expectations for this
company they what are people buying it
has a great question it depends on on
you know there's there's actually a
great amount of variation there too I
mean it's you know yes or Bank or or
file coin slash protocol labs or tezo's
I mean I think across the board people
who tried a lotta different models
everything from you're buying a utility
token which is the ultimately going to
be used for some sort of functional
utility inside the network as part of a
product yeah - hey literally you're
giving money to a foundation that's like
literally it's a donation to a
foundation and you have no expectation
of anything in return it's like if
you're if you read the docs that's
actually what you did you donate it to a
foundation so it's actually pretty broad
spectrum and so there's no Universal
answer to that and I actually think it's
it it will be interesting to see what
happens on the regulatory side on that I
think in the next you know 12 months
says some of these things come to
fruition where people don't actually
deliver on projects you know I think
it's a big open question of what
actually happens in which of these
things are okay and which of them or not
yeah what's crazy is like there's I mean
you can't even possibly spend that much
money on developing applications like I
disagree
someone's gonna spend the money oh my
god but like people now have so much
excess capital that they're giving it to
crypt of funds and being like you manage
this capital and now they're like an LP
so it's like so crazy some of these
projects have become funds of funds yeah
yeah and in some cases you could argue
you know what like I think if the
etherium Community Fund is doing an
interesting job here we're saying hey
look if your room is actually a really
go system we want to encourage
development in the ecosystem let's
invest in teams and companies doing
really interesting work that may may be
under invested in like a lot of
infrastructure stuff is just under
invested in so it's like let's give
developers an incentive to pay attention
there but yeah in certain other cases
it's just like hey we raised 200 million
dollars and by the way that 5x so now we
have a billion dollars and we're not
actually equipped to handle a billion
dollars we really only need it 25
million dollars to build the thing so
what we're gonna do with 975 million
dollars right I mean you also have to be
a money manager and that's right
founders who's like how much is liquid
how much is 200 how much do I pay people
which then I think that Linda's point is
okay well we probably don't want to be
money manager so let's go find a money
manager and are handing their money over
to people to be money managers yeah
crazy so on on the founders side what
are you guys saying to people that are
honestly considering an SEO and they've
passed the threshold where you're like
okay this actually makes sense you're
not just like generating some pyramid
scheme you're not just trying to grab
money and and there's a real reason to
do it what do you tell them so so a very
very few times is it reasonable in my
opinion to do a token sale there's a lot
of really great projects that can do
decentralize applications or create
their own blockchain River but they
don't actually need to do a token sale
they can just go traditional equity
route and we seen that with the with
some projects like Dharma and dy/dx so I
actually recommend a lot of projects to
go that route because you don't
necessarily want to attack on a token
that you don't know is actually going to
make sense it creates additional
friction to the network as well and
there's there's still regulatory
uncertainty as how this is supposed to
be handled so if someone still really
wants to do a token sale I I recommend
that they work with lawyers that really
understand the space don't try to be
cheap with the lawyers I've heard people
be like oh I found some like discount
lawyer he's willing to do this
can sell for really chief and I'm like
no like you want to make sure people
have expertise around this and can guide
you through things but I generally also
say like and no-one's listened to me on
this but I think they should raise the
series like there's no need that you
have to raise all that money up front
let's say you really wanted to raise all
that money up front you should probably
like lock it up for some time and as you
hit certain milestones the funds then
release because it can also sitting on
like 200 million dollars can also kind
of hurt incentives of the team being
like oh we just have a bunch of money
like we can just spend like crazy so I
think that the incentives really change
and the last thing which people have
listened to me on is the vesting
schedule of tokens so it's really
important to just kind of look like a
traditional company in that sense is you
want to make sure employees aren't just
gonna leave and cash out their tokens
right when the tokens still happens and
on the flip side you for investors you
you want to make sure they're aligned
with you as well yeah early on a lot of
projects didn't have a vesting schedule
or lock up for these investors and the
investor just came in and flipped their
coins they got their discount like
twenty to thirty percent and then during
the actual token sale they just sold
everything and they're no longer
investors so you it really changes
incentives so it's so important to think
through how your token model actually
works and what are the like what's the
governance of it essentially do you
recommend for your vesting for employees
same deal yeah that's pretty much what
I've been doing so for like one year
lock of one your lockup when you're
locked word for your investing schedule
that's what I've been recommending but I
mean yeah it's it's pretty
tried-and-true I mean I think a lot of
these things like vesting or you know
being being thoughtful about when you
raise money and how you raise money
they're tried-and-true for a reason
right they're actually like underlying
it all is there's a group of humans that
get in a room or getting a telegram
group and write some code and and those
human dynamics haven't really changed
and so things like vesting are
importantly I think we figured that out
over the last 20 years that some of
these things are really good now I think
there are places where you might want to
like reconsider them in your like in in
this new world like you know how much
where's the value accrue is it equity or
tokens so are your employees vesting
equity or they vesting tokens so they're
like some interesting questions there
but I think some of these foundational
concepts like vesting they exist for a
reason
and I think their best practice for a
reason and I think a lot of teens should
be adopting these things if they haven't
already
mm-hmm yeah I mean it's trick it like
again when you get a bunch of humans in
a room they create games and if you
raise a billion I'm gonna raise a
billion one yeah that's the game yeah
yeah unfortunately yeah so so to like
kind of boil it down you're saying to
founders like listen you don't
necessarily have to do token sale yeah
because it's not required so if you're a
founder and you're interested in crypto
you can get in but you don't have to do
this right and so when it comes back to
that like are you saying to them you
know apply to an accelerator or go and
raise money traditionally like what are
you recommending them to do in that path
yeah I think what it comes down to is
just like outside of crypto and startup
world at this point there are a lot of
places to get money and and I know it's
different if you're in different parts
of the world in some places have more
investor depth and investor liquidity
than other places but you know there
there are a lot of ways to raise money
and so you really want to be thoughtful
about who you're raising money from and
what value they bring to your company
and yeah you could do the ico and get a
bunch of people to send you some eath
but what happens if things don't go well
all right or the you know those are the
kinds of projects I think that you know
your your retail investor raises up
their hand and says that person stole my
money
meanwhile they're they're always great
investors like Linda who have actually
been at companies and like started
companies and helped scale companies and
that's actually who you want involved
right that's actually who can help you
over the next three four or five years
as you build your company so I think
what we're gonna see is a lot of people
returning to that idea of oh well I
could get money from five different
places who can actually add value to my
company for the next three to five years
and help me build this company and so I
think we'll see that sort of
re-aggravate ords people who actually
add value in the early stages you know
that could be an accelerator that could
be an early stage investor that could be
somebody who was early in crypto and
made a bunch of money but actually is
very sophisticated about how they think
about Krypton right a lot of those
people out there too so it's not to say
you know people who haven't previously
been in the ecosystem or not value add I
think there are actually a lot of people
who are crypto native in some sense who
really understand this stuff right and
I've been in it for years we're very
smart and very thoughtful and you want
them involved and so it's real
about how do you find people who can add
value and get them involved in your
company and being smart and thoughtful
about that yeah yeah that's that's so
true just because when when these
projects are doing token sales they're
distributing their tokens to thousands
of people and especially if you did some
heavy marketing around that you end up
getting this like pump-and-dump kind of
crowd and all they're doing is saying
like when moon when the bellowing acts
like they just want things listed in the
price to pump yeah and then if you look
at those slack groups it's just like
mayhem they're just they're not adding
any value they're creating tons of
distraction for the founders and so I
think it's so important to have value
add investors and not just try to make
money really really quick or something I
mean I think you see the micro example
in Silicon Valley already right like if
you're a big quotes hot company you can
raise from anyone yeah it's just about
finding the smartest money yeah until
you see that in a larger scale here it's
like zillions of dollars floating around
yeah how do I actually think in the last
three months in particular don't know if
you're saying this but it seems like we
have moved back into that world where
the really really good teams in crypto
and a lot of the teams that have a lot
of early momentum are going out and
seeking out the high-value investors
again and saying like hey I don't want
to do a public sale I actually want to
find people who can add value to the
company and be thoughtful about it so um
I mean I think we might look at this
historically you know in five years we
might look back and say oh that was a
funny six month window in time yeah I
kind of like basically getting back to
the basic principles I saw some stat on
that I was saying like nowadays 60% of
the funds raised in a general token sale
is actually raised in the presale round
so it's it's really shift in momentum so
far just in a year since beginning of
the year yeah yeah cool yeah things move
so fast in space all right so let's go
into some of the questions from Twitter
King Croesus asks so what are your
thoughts on optional versus mandatory
privacy in transactions yes have a lot
of thoughts on that so I essentially
think that it needs to be mandatory
privacy if you're gonna actually have a
privacy coin if it's ever if it's ever
optional you get looked at if you're
starting to use a privacy feature like
why are you using this privacy feature
do you have something to hide so first
of all it like paint a target on your
back second of all so for context I did
I did blockchain tracing when I was at
bass and so bitcoin is very easy to
trace and a lot of people give
information away about other people so
even if you're being really smart and
someone trans acts with you they give
away away information about you and so
that can happen in a scenario where you
only have a small subset that's actually
being private and the rest of the the
users on the network are being public
they can give that information away so I
think it's really important to just have
mandatory privacy and that's something I
really love about Manero that's they
have all transactions are private by
default and I think that's that's
absolutely crucial yeah I feel sorry I
think I think mandatory is already go I
think it creates some interesting
challenges though I think that's a
harder pill for regulators to swallow
generally speaking I heard this great
story where in the early days of the
internet you know like SSL HTTPS is now
like a standard thing right and it's on
by default in a lot of cases but
actually the Netscape team had to fight
to make that a thing that was possible
inside the browser because the
government was worried about like why do
you need to encrypt your transactions
like you know you are you doing
something illegal like why shouldn't we
have this be public and it turned out
that one of the one of the selling
points was commerce it's like you don't
want to send your credit card number
over the wire unencrypted and and so the
fact that there were like real
legitimate use cases allowed things like
SSL to emerge is like oh yeah we should
actually allow that and so that that I
think is actually the the challenge for
the space is philosophically you agree
with Linda with Linda which I do I think
then the onus is on us to demonstrate
all the use cases where default privacy
is really important and I think things
like hey look if people do start to get
paid in crypto for their job well you
kind of don't want everybody to know how
much what do you make and who's paying
you that's like that's reasonable I
think it's even more interesting if you
start talking about well let's say you
have a particular sexual orientation and
you live in a community that doesn't
really support that and you're donating
to a charity that does like do you
really want people to be able to sniff
that out you take an even more extreme
when you say well if you live in a
a country where the government is not
you know you might trust the US
government there might be other
government that you don't trust well do
you want even if that's not your
government do you want that government
to be able to sniff out your
transactions on a public law chain right
right and so I think being really
concrete about it's not it's not just a
philosophical thing though I do agree
with the philosophy hundred percent is
there are like really practical
consequences to this stuff what will
make it possible I think for regulators
to understand why it's so important that
it be on by default yeah absolutely and
and also there is this concept of
selective transparency and both Manero
and Z cache so you could centrally have
this view key where you can share with
someone to now view your transactions
really um so this you could share with
auditors if you want to be compliant or
if a charity just wants to display those
transactions they can share their view
key to everyone in the world so that the
the idea is that it really much just
mirrors the traditional financial system
we don't broadcast everything to the
world but we download our bank account
statement and give it to someone when
they need to see it um so I don't think
like it is far off from what we're just
used to right agreed
yeah yeah so just default private and
then if you need to be public on it yes
yeah cool so transitioning from that
into another governmental related
question cláudio asks how do you see the
US government or do you see the US
government launching their own crypto
currency backed by gold yeah I have very
strong thoughts about this so so the
specific incarnation I think backed by
gold we can sort of set that aside for a
second in general I think I hear a lot
of people talking about how governments
might regulate crypto or ban crypto and
and there is some risk of that I think
the bigger and scarier potential risk is
that governments fully embrace crypto in
the wrong way hmm and so kind of back
this idea of privacy right like do you
really want a government that you may
not trust to have full visibility into
everything that you are spending money
on every day and every transaction and
every person that you're transacting
with right that has like very you know
there's like fundamental human right to
privacy sorts of aspects to that and
then like very practical you know if if
your government can do it odds are other
governments can do it sorts of
downstream consequences and so you know
increasingly I think governments are
getting stuff
in a way that they think about
technology and adopting technology and
using technology so I think the bigger
risk is actually what Claudio is calling
out is governments being really smart
about adopting this in a way that makes
in my opinion the wrong trade-offs
between sort of security versus privacy
mmm and and I think they're just not
enough there's not enough people I think
we're so many people are worried about
governments banning the stuff that we're
not looking at the other side of it
nearly as deeply of what happens if a
government fully embraces it and but
does it in the wrong way or what if a a
government that you may not trust even
if you trust your government if another
government that you don't trust embraces
it in the wrong way is there a positive
outcome in which a government embraces
it creates for example us Coyne whatever
it might be
Trump coin yeah where it's actually not
not a negative thing or that you we move
from the dollar to us corner it is
possible yeah a lot I think absolutely I
mean that's what's that's one of the
great things I think about crypto is it
is global and I think there are there
are all sorts of opportunities for
governments that are especially smaller
and more nimble and willing to adopt
this stuff I think Estonia has done a
great job of pioneering some of this
stuff
I think Singapore is poking around with
this so there are definitely places
between voting or making it easy to file
your taxes to you know making the
banking system more efficient there are
lots of places I think where large
existing institutions could adopt this
and that'd be great
or you know even making stable coins
like you know maybe some government
should just say hey look we we have five
hundred billion dollars and you trust us
and we're going to stable coins and now
actually crypto can be a real thing
so I think there are lots of positive
ways governments could play in the space
as well and hopefully some well yeah
yeah Dubai has been pretty good about
that they said that like all visa
applications and some other documents
would be on the blockchain by 2020 so
they it ended up like it's gonna save
them over a billion dollars a year and
just be more efficient so they're
they've been pioneers in the space and I
know consensus the company works really
closely with them and then now that yeah
I quickly agree with everything you said
what's crazy is Venezuela already issued
their own yeah yeah which they claim
there are five billion dollars with
grades in the presale but they haven't
proved it but what's crazy is that
there's all these sanctions against
Venezuela and now there's this foreign
capital coming in apparently to to fund
this and so you you run into all these
issues we're like now you're you're
supporting a sanction country
financially and so that they'll be
really interesting to watch how that
plays out right well I mean you see
every day how little the average you
know normal person cares about these
sanctions between borders so by
something in Venezuela or Mexico or it
doesn't matter yeah all right another
question Naveen Mishra asked what would
be the best onboarding ramps for
adoption and what roles will Oracle's
have in decision-making in the future so
best onboarding ramps for adoption I
mean honestly I think it's something
like coinbase they do a really good job
of just linking up your bank account and
just purchasing crypto currencies so I
think that just having a nice user
experience there is really important I
think the more interesting thing for me
is what role will Oracle's have in the
decision making process so I'm
fascinated with this idea of
decentralized Oracle's
so you could essentially have a system
like augur which is a prediction market
platform where anyone can create a
prediction market on it and the the past
issue with prediction markets is they
often get shut down by regulators just
because it's kind of closer to gambling
but in in prediction markets on top
auger no one can shut this down so you
can really have these markets operate
and so people can start creating markets
where essentially you measure the
citizens happiness you measure GDP you
measure all these different statistics
of a different of a country and you can
have people betting on the outcome of
whether or not a different policy is
going to increase or decrease these
statistics and from there policymakers
can now start making their decisions
based off the outcome of this and that's
called free turkey and I just think that
is so cool because it people are
actually putting their money where their
mouth is at this point so like they
might say one thing oh yeah I really
support this policy but if they're
actually betting on it then that's
that's more I think a stronger signal so
I I think that that's going to be
something that is totally new that that
these systems are able to produce so
yeah the only thing I had on the
onboarding piece of it is I I suspect
that the way most people will get on
boarded will either be very directly
like coinbase it's like they know what
they're getting into they're buying into
a crypto or it's gonna be totally opaque
to them they're actually not gonna
realize at all that what they're doing
is interacting with blockchain and
crypto they're just doing a thing that
you couldn't do before right and it's
just gonna be so it's gonna be so
sideways and that people just won't
realize it that's actually what's
happening and I suspect those native use
cases will be that way and so I think
you know it's an interesting question of
what percentage of people on board it
into the space do it very directly
through something like one base or they
just happen to do a thing and that
happens to sit on top of crypto kind of
it kinda reminds me of you know like
several years ago we used to talk about
mobile companies so right now we talk
about clear definite ways and in some
point in like the next five years it's
not going to be that your crypto
companies that you offer some value to
the people who use your product and it
just so happens that you sit on top of
blockchain you're using economics or
whatever and so I think that will
actually be how a lot of this stuff goes
mainstream is in a way that people don't
even associate directly with crypto
necessarily yeah I think I like I would
bet a hundred percent on that because if
you ask the average person like so what
language is Facebook and what what's a
language why do I care about this and
you see it when people pitching their
companies so they're like we have the
fastest implementation of Python you've
ever seen
no one cares yeah good point
awesome well thanks for coming in guys
this has been really great yeah thanks
you